something happened here dude it really
cranks something happened that was not
fair
hey what's going on everybody first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by rich Bryan his debut
album Amen is out now and for those of
you in San Francisco LA or New York you
can catch him this month on 88 risings
Double Happiness to our Brian welcome to
the show
Thank You Sean not our first spicy meal
together but I have to ask how are you
with hot food I've been so curious about
like how hot these wings actually are
because I'm pretty good with hot food
you know I just love to eat just like
chili flakes and rice well it sounds
like you have a good foundation we have
the chocolate milk on deck the wings are
sauced and ready to go you want to get
it started we'll do it
[Music]
all right all right good so let's start
with the rich Brian blueprint because
against all odds you're able to build
this massive audience as a teenager home
schooled in Indonesia and I wonder at
that time in your life how many hours a
day were you spending on the internet
like 24 hours I was just like I loo I
had nothing else to do all of you is
just go on YouTube look at toy videos or
people vlogging vlogs were like my [ __ ]
back then
dude I was watching like this this dude
I was watching the randoms people ever
because did call ericsurf6 this American
dude is living in Japan eating food just
everybody that talks to the camera and
like speaks English because that was
like what I was into it's so interesting
because you end up learning and
experiencing American culture yeah
through YouTube and through memes which
is such an interesting curriculum it's
such a bizarre curriculum can you give
me one pro of that in one con with memes
and everything I got to learn like the
American sense of humor because it's so
different from the Indonesians of the
humor it took me like a while to like
really learn it but the cause of it
there's so many weird [ __ ] on the
internet that is not really normal in
real life I'm very problematic and I
learned that like way back then I'm like
okay like okay so this is the sense of
humor yeah yeah you know so some things
are just warped through them you know
blends of the Internet so that's the
condom
[Music]
okay I like it a lot it's not that much
spicier than the previous one though we
inch it up over here Brian you know it's
not that steep of ramp dude that's what
I thought it was I was paired actually
no I wasn't this is like sorry I'm
talking with my food in my mouth but it
happens on the show I'm like doing like
all this press stuff and this is the
only thing that I'm not nervous for like
my manager asked me today in the car
like are you ready for hard ones before
you even finish all yes I just like I've
always wanted to be on the show this is
an amazing journey we've always wanted
to have yeah so last we spoke had been
ages since you were home in Jakarta and
that obviously changed recently in
December you were able to do a hometown
show is that the first time you'd ever
performed in front of your parents yeah
that like it was amazing it was a little
too long for them so they were watching
from the balcony up above I did like a
little shout out my parents and then
like all the crap I click that they kind
of like hit a little bit but it was
super fun man it was like the first time
that they saw me in my element
did you get a chance to introduce them
to Joji yeah yeah dude my parents loved
you really sister loves you go dude they
all went to my house and my neighbor's I
liked taking pictures with Joe G and
yeah I didn't know how they even knew
about Joe G but like he's got that
worldwide appeal mm-hmm I'm so hungry
though
LM occasionally though so your Twitter's
full of gems from the brain of rich
Brian but some of them leave more
questions than answers are you still up
on your new year's resolution to eat
more cheese platters oh yeah I had a
cheese platter on the plane on the way
here from my lane the lady was like do
you want this a really big chicken lap
which was probably better for me or a
cheese plate no like cheese plate you
say Rick and Morty and porn are the
biggest influences to your music I
understand that it's difficult to get
porn in Indonesia what's the workaround
[Music]
the workaround is um my parents are
probably gonna be watching this so I
don't know what you talking about it I
don't what is part I would say use VPN
wwk proxy comm it will show up you can
type in whatever you want and it'll you
know give you the access what is it
about the Geico lizard that turns you on
[Music]
there's this um about lizards man I was
super into dinosaurs
I drew dinosaurs a lot when I was a kid
and so you know at one point where my
parents said that it was satanic and
made me throw away all my drawings
Geico I feel like combine the coolness
of the lizard and then mixed it with
yeah they have an accent and like that I
feel like the accent is what made it
hard why can all life's problems be
solved by listening to life there's a
highway because life is a highway and I
just want to can write like all day long
I like that I like that a lot do you
make those off me and Chris in the
bathtub
wow so we recently met up and you
schooled me in Indonesian cuisine at
Bali kitchen in New York but I have it
on good authority from one of our mutual
friends I'm talking about the double
cheap top one himself bill ratchet yes
you can get it done in the kitchen as
well right what's your signature dish
and can you describe how to make it in
as much detail as possible my mom's
gonna be so mad at me because this is
her recipe and I'm giving up to the
world but it is called do you know
dancer try saying it Tina Renza yep you
got it so the original dish is pork but
I didn't really want it to be too heavy
so I use chicken this seasoning is
turmeric there's some ginger there's
definitely a lot of pepper like habanero
you know like there's like some other
stuff but you just lend it all up
[Music]
and then you marinate the meat with it I
just like put it all a little big bowl
and mix it around and then I put it in
the fridge and then while it's in the
fridge I make the rice feel like that's
like a good marinate time they just put
it in the pan and then just cut the [ __ ]
out of it man you give it to your
friends it's a bill ratchet he tried
that and if you loved it cooking for
people it's like such a pure thing to do
it's like saying I love you without
saying it
oh hey man Jack yeah breakfast before
this so thanks for asking ollie real
light you know maybe a banana in the
morning maybe I'll have like a quarter
of a bagel with some jelly I don't want
to be on a completely empty stomach
right but you know you have like a full
meal and then you eat these wings and
then they have all this hot sauce on
them and then you just end up full yeah
I'm like full of hot sauce and like milk
and water you'd have to like roll me out
of here I've made that mistake before
but it's like painful was it been like
was it the first couple episodes no it
was the Thomas Middleditch episode which
is way too deep into the game right I
make that kind of mistake but by the end
of it I'm like whoa I'm gonna just puke
on my own show hmm all right rich Brian
so every current segment on our show
called explain that grammar into a deep
dive on our guest Instagram cool
interesting pictures that need more
contacts with doing so I'll show you the
picture and you tell me the bigger story
does that sound good good laptop please
all right
up first we got hmm so that was me and
ago there's a life a lot of stray goats
in my neighborhood it's pretty sad
actually because me and the whole eighty
arising team we all went to Indonesia
and then like they went to the
neighborhood and all the goats were not
there because it was the annual holiday
where people would sacrifice the gods so
all the girls are dead at the time but
in this picture that good was still
alive hanging out with Jaden Smith in
the best day of my life I woke up this
one morning I tweeted out New York was
good like I'd never tweet anything like
that because that's like I never like
really found like a reason to do it but
that morning it just felt right yes I
did it and then Jaden facetimes me like
whoa
it was a yo what's up he's like where
are you and I'm like I'm in New York and
he's like ya know what why are you
though and I'm like man he's like I know
like where are you that and then I was
like I'm in shelli's market he's like
hangout and I'm like hell yeah we just
had the craziest day ever he was with
his friends they were all like
skateboarding and we like went to palace
the palace door and then he like bought
me a skateboard and I was like oh my god
that's seriously and then we all just
like skated the whole day I didn't know
how to skate he like taught me how to
skate it was a blast man and then later
that night we watched Navy driver went
home at like 3 a.m. it was soo Berlin
one for the history books
yes one more for you what's going on
here I was like just taking the bathroom
no reason I put on like the towel
because I didn't want to be exposed oh
he's walking and then there was a gate
like a huge mirror and I looked at it
and I was like damn I kind of like look
good right now so I just pulled out my
phone post this is my favorite pose ever
and then I just like took a picture and
that was a picture
[Music]
red pepper butternut squash you guys I
can marinate the chicken then like so
[ __ ] all right
so Dom Dom did you make them today so
Dom tell me if I'm wrong on this right
you'll put the sauce in a bowl you'll
put the wings in the bowl you'll toss
the wings in the bowl and then it'll go
on the on the plate right and so you'll
have 20 bowls total right there 10 bowls
total so each sauce has its own bowl
that's all gets tossed in full coverage
that's how the hot ones platter is
served that's great I never like heard
anybody talk about that but that's the
really cool process I understand that
you're living in Los Angeles but haven't
laid down steaks on a permanent home yet
so you're doing extended stays at Airbnb
and there's really an art when it comes
to finessing the Airbnb what are some of
your red flags what are some of the
warning signs when you're going into it
the Lambs have to be like not white just
cuz it just I hate white lambs man I
mean you know this is like we got a
little white lamp situation I don't mind
it because it's a studio but like it's
like a house and you're living in it you
don't want it to feel like a hospital I
don't like when I could walk in and sort
of smell prom pictures and like an
eighth grade right day right then like
see pictures on the refrigerator you
know what I mean I never like to feel
like I'm in a house that's like been
really lived in I actually loved it you
do I love it so much
what's the best discovery that you've
ever made at a spot you've ever walked
into a spot no I call [ __ ] they have one
of these it was a really beautiful like
decorated spot but then the first thing
that I thought it was like there has to
be weed somewhere hidden in here and I
was just looking for every single day I
felt really stupid but then one day I
was just trying to make some pasta right
and then I was in the kitchen and I was
like looking for the pasta looking for
some ingredients and then there's like I
saw this coffee box with
a little a little like baggy kind of
popping out of it and I was like what's
going on here and sure enough you know
found some mid how do you think I'm
doing right now like compared to like
other people that might be it for joke
you know what's been the most
interesting fan encounter that you've
had so far because I heard that you had
somebody break into your home recently
and present you with three boxes of
noodles
which I didn't eat you're watching out
there I did not get that and I hate it
but I feel like the weirdest fan
interactions have always happened in
Asia they have like so much like
repressed craziness you know they're
like very calm like nice people but then
like you know this one time that I was
just walking around in night market in
China and then this 30 year old lady
just like charged at me she was with her
boyfriends here she just like like
screaming just like hugged me to the
point where it was kind of like yo is
she gonna like kill me and you know like
my my manager was there he was like yeah
like Choa Choa some people are just like
a very passionate about meeting their
idols and I'm a very shy person I don't
know how people can just like approach
people like that beyond insanity
I like that flavor a lot you can hold it
gives me like a very oh my god mmm
it's a creeper creeper this one gives
you like a boom like a bomb kind of vine
yeah okay so for many hip-hop fans you
burst onto the scene with that stick
something happened here dude it really
cranks something happened that was not
for him so for many hip-hop fans you
burst onto the scene with that stick
where you supported the hardest softest
look of all time the tuck job the fanny
pack so what I want to do is show you
some other iconic looks from fanny pack
enthusiasts and I'm just curious about
the looks that you like the ones that
you don't like and then maybe we can
crown a king does that sound good huh
all right laptop please how you doing
[Music]
up first we have logic with an album art
fanny pack I like that a lot
I usually don't like stuff that has
pictures on it Jesus [ __ ] you jest
this is actually but that's you know
good to get on him get on logic next we
have Kendall Jenner more of a
high-fashion fanny pack Laura Danna is
that Gucci right there where's the L
beam that's Louie Vuitton alveen I like
that I mean I like the the fact that
some more people are getting into fanny
packs I think it's a really dope looks
and I wish that were my fanny pack today
you feel like I would have done better
with that wing Lee's gonna be tearing up
right now a little bit I did the
chocolate milk
oh you did quavo quavo be back and
sometimes he'll toss it over the
shoulder if you ever seen the toss over
the shoulder look tiny packs are called
fanny packs cuz it just gives you gets
you a lot of Fanny's but I feel like
quavo doesn't need it cuz he's just so
Iced Out it's not fair like it can't
just wear all that all you know all that
jewelry and like diamonds and then wear
a fanny pack
it's like save some money for the rest
of us dude
this one is mad dog 357 with number nine
plutonium
what is the number and I put on him
[Music]
probably go hot - you don't kind of
flavor mm-hmm dude I feel like what's
going on right now it's like so
interesting cuz it doesn't feel like an
interview I was like walking into the
building just feels like I'm catching up
with an old friend you know over some
because you are over some really hot
wings for some reason what's a lovely
segue talking about friends because
you've talked about how you cook for
your friends and when you were coming up
you created this whole network of
friends some of which round the other
side of the globe and people say that
this generation it's so selfish it's so
self-absorbed but you seem to have a
special insight when it comes to the art
of the bromance and nowhere is that more
apparent than in a relationship with
post Malone and these birthday surprises
run it you guys pull down each other
what was it like to hear my gospel choir
singing blow like that that was great
man they're the coolest people ever they
were just like Ashlee like showing me
love like yo like I'm you know Congrats
on all the success and I'm like wow
that's super dope I thought they were
just like do it and then leave but they
were like really cool people was getting
a mariachi band to play congratulations
the sweetest thing you've ever done for
a fellow bro yeah the sweetest thing
I've ever done for anybody
I've never even like like done that to
like a female which I probably should
it's kind of hard to top that now what
are your tips for turning an Internet
friend into an IRL friend you meet
certain people and they're just like so
late like they just like they're either
really obnoxious or just like you know a
little too shy but you know I understand
I was a shy following myself but then um
some people just don't expect this being
close with and like with you man I'm
hitting off with you we're eating wings
together and
you know he should hang out with Bill
ratchet by the way like while I'm in New
York yeah yeah he really wants to hang
out love you
double cheek tup double cheek tough one
of Thursday afternoon yeah let's not
break this one again oh yeah yeah
remember we smash the bottle yeah all
right so this is the last dab we call it
the last dab because it's tradition
around here to put a little extra on the
last wing you don't have to I will if
you don't want to I will I will
you know if I don't can you actually put
it online I'm depending on you to
okay brother Judah Brian Cheers
[Music]
alright Brian here we are with a half
gallon of chocolate milk ten kinds of
hot sauce in our bellies and before we
get you out of here I just have one last
question I've heard just say that if you
didn't get into the rap game that you
would have instead ended up in the film
lane so I'm curious with a gazillion
scovilles coursing through you can you
pitch your dream film project to me it's
much detail uh dream foam project I
really I mean honestly I really want to
be in stranger things dude it's just
like you know I'm like a little older
than some of them but like my goal is
just to be that one friend that's like
you know personality could be anything
could be goofy it could be an [ __ ] I
feel like I would do like a movie about
like a guy that just deals truffles
because that actually exists makes it
like a really serious thing where
there's gangsters and there's shootouts
happening and people getting killed over
truffle one that has no hot wings in it
because I [ __ ] you know I hate it now
you are comfortable and the Scoville
spot right that much is for sure and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you my man making it
through the hot ones gauntlet cleaning
wings dabbing it on the last dab doing
it all the way through this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know or that camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life I
have an album that is out called Amen
please check that out
I like it a lot it's my first ever
project and
[Music]
dude I had coffee before like this red
black coffee so first of all it you know
like suppress my appetite so it was like
a little hard to go through the wings
second of all it's it's a chemistry
experiment in there yeah so something
okay what's going on hot ones fans it's
Sean Evans and you know what I'm not
going to beg for your subscription if
you're not subscribed turn off the video
it's over I want just my subscribers
come here come here if you're subscribed
to first we feast I just want to say
thank you and then I appreciate you that
I love you and I hope that you have a
great day